it's a great honor and it's a great
pleasure to be able to celebrate
dude with as you will notice a stellar
group of speakers but also to have an
audience of more than a thousand people
here today before I turn the floor to
our keynote lecture Paul Wolfe which I
would like to say a few words about
twenty years of nexus Institute and the
topic of today's conference in a certain
way the Nexus Institute has grown out of
a book
death tower bear the magic mountain of
thomas mann a book which I read more
than three decades ago now those among
you have read the book will recollect
that the core of the story are the
conversations between two antagonists
one of them mr. Sethi blini who is
representing the idealism of the
Enlightenment and his opponent NAFTA who
represents the dark sides but also true
realism of the dark sides of Romanticism
and in between the two of them is two
young protagonists hands cast-off who
with an open mind listens to both their
arguments and has to make up his own
mind
now in essence this is what the nexus
conferences are all about for over 20
years we organized the conversation
between people with different sometimes
even opposite views and based upon their
arguments you the audience can make up
your own mind and of course after the
conversation you run to the bookshop you
buy your pile of books to get more food
for Ford and as some of you may know
it's a fact at the cart before he wrote
cogito ergo zoom wrote they go ergo zoom
I read therefore I am anyway the magic
mountain of Thomas Marvel and with the
beginning of World War one its 1914 and
hands cast off to has to go to war as a
soldier and probably he will not survive
important for us is that the young man
is taken by surprise
not for a second he high on the mountain
reading his books having big
conversations expected a war and then
Thomas Monk comments in a one hour onyx
enters he said Hans Gustav has failed to
rate to read the daily newspapers and it
was a self-criticism for him as well
because he was very well aware of the
fact that for way too long he has lived
in his ivory tower of culture and
ignoring politics now so this is two
part of the mission of the Nexxus
Institute trying to close the gap
between the world of culture intellects
and politics the world of those who have
time to read and write books and
practitioners who have power but also
responsibilities war and peace the topic
of our 20th anniversary conference is a
timeless but unfortunately also a very
timely topic and it's a topic which can
only be discussed in sensible bay by
what we did we brought together today
practitioners politicians diplomats and
public intellectuals amongst magic
mountain there is a deep but often
unnoticed comment about war and peace
which is that as long as the two atanga
nice to talk with each other there will
be no war yet at the very moment one of
them refuses to continue the
conversation which is NAFTA the next
step is violence which is always the
case at the very moment the conversation
stops there is were violence or even war
begins now
almost every time when we send out our
program for a nexus conference there are
always some people who criticize us that
we have invited speak X Y or Z because
and then you get a whole series of
prejudices speak exes and extreme
leftist or he said reactionary
philosophers
still in favor of hunting or he's a
dangerous scientist so he's just a very
boring scholar and my reply is and will
always be a quote out of own liberty of
John Stuart Mill which is that you can
only gain some wisdom if you have the
courage and the patience to listen first
to everything that can be said against
your own views and engage into a
conversation all I can't cast off in a
Magic Mountain listen first with an open
mind of to the views and ideas of others
before you drown before you draw your
own conclusions now within these spirits
we convey our Nexus conferences and I
don't pretend or even think for a second
that we can change the world but what I
do think is that an intelligent public
conversation about the most urgent
questions of our time is a small but
necessary contribution to cultivate a
peaceful society
you